so when I first started a podcast I put
a call out to people call with what's
going on in your mental health and your
relationships what's going on with your
kids people would call and they would
tell me this really intimate thing or
this really intense situation my first
question was often why are you calling
me call your friend have you talked to
your wife about this and without fail
every single person responded with one
terrifying response man I got nobody
else to
call
so here's what's Wild we communicate
with more people than any other humans
have ever communicated in the history of
this planet we have more people in our
orbit than ever before and we are the
loneliest generation that has ever
walked this Earth and if you're like me
over the last decade I have found myself
communicating more and more and more and
my body's been feeling less and less
connected
communication is not
connection technology it's great where
are you who are you how's your mom but
technology does not permit connection
for the first time in human history we
are tribess
people we've pulled the thread on every
one of the things that bound us together
we've pulled the threat on education and
on medicine and on politics we used to
lean on these important pillars of our
society and they're
gone and we're left with these shiny
Little Boxes full of people who hate the
people we hate and who like the things
that we like and we're living in these
splintered realities and here's what's
wild about how our brains work when your
brain identifies that you're alone when
your brain understands when your body
feels and knows that your tribe has left
you it instantly divides the world up
between uses and thems it looks for
people who are just like you in order to
stay safe we need an us and everyone
else becomes
them you ever wonder why 40-year-old
guys get together and they've been
friends since high school and they just
tell the same high school football
stories over and over again because for
most of us that was the last time we
were a part of something bigger than
ourselves and then we graduated wait
then we get out of the military we walk
across that stage and without warning it
suddenly in an instant becomes the world
vers me if I make a sale it's because
you didn't if I win it's because you
lost and our bodies go to war and you're
busy at work and you're busy at home and
you're busy keeping up with the Joneses
and now that we have smartphones
everyone is the Joneses and we're
running and running and running and we
wake up and we're 33 or we're 41 or
we're 29 or we're 55 and we have no
one and this isn't me just spitball and
I'm not just making this up in 2022
Ramsey Solutions ran an extensive survey
across the country just trying to get a
state of people's relationships what we
found was devastating 82% of people said
that people they spend the most time
with have no idea what's really going on
deep inside almost 70% have three or few
are close friends over 50% more than
half of the respondents said they did
not have a single person they felt safe
enough to call in the middle of the
night if they had an emergency of course
our bodies aren't letting us sleep of
course our bodies don't want to be
intimate of course our bodies all have
digestion issues because they are trying
to not die because we have no one when's
the last time any of us truly felt like
we
[Music]
belong a life of loneliness is a
choice choosing loneliness is choosing
to live a life of
anxiety choosing loneliness to be honest
is choosing to die early loneliness has
been implicated clinically in every
everything from heart attacks to cancer
to dementia increases your risk for
addiction for suicide for mental health
challenges and when you choose
loneliness and you choose to die early
you're also choosing to take everybody
else down with you cuz your kids are
wondering what was so bad about me that
Dad didn't reach out what was wrong with
me what was so bad about me that my wife
wouldn't tell me what was in her heart
choosing loneliness is choosing misery
and you got to hear me say this you you
are worth so much
more and so where do we go from here
where do we go what I'm going to say
sounds like flowers and rainbows and
little blue birds fluttering around our
heads I get it I know the path forward
the path towards choosing connection is
you have to choose
love I remember asking a buddy who was
an active Navy SEAL you'll love each
other when you're out on deployment he
responded with a unique
and special kind of love it's a kind of
love that will lay your life down for
somebody else who will say if not me
then who it's a love that says all go
first it's a love about purpose love
doesn't mean soft and love doesn't mean
weak and love doesn't mean giving up
your power and love doesn't mean having
no boundaries this is rooted in
Neuroscience love calms the body love
connects you are who you are in space
and within your own body because you
were connected or because you're
disconnected because you were loved or
because you were unloved so we have to
understand that most of us don't have
good models for connection most of us
don't have good pictures of what love
even looks and feels like for most of us
love came at a cost we got love when we
achieved we got love when we acted right
we got love when we made other people
look good or other people feel good and
that's not love when a body is loved
when a body is connected the body can be
at peace otherwise you are running
around as an anxious chaotic mess love
is the foundation of a non-anxious life
it's the foundation of connection you
are fully
seen and you are fully heard and you are
fully
known and you're loved
anyway so what do you do if you don't
have a good picture you don't have a
good model but you know you got to I I
want you to think of love and connection
as skills things you got to practice
things that you don't know how to do but
that you know you got to learn and
making new friends as an adult it's the
worst it's the worst how can you ever
recreate the friendships you experienced
in your sorority and your fraternity you
can't those were special and unique the
challenge isn't recreating what already
existed the challenge is building
something new
some practical steps towards connection
some practical steps towards love show
up volunteer go first if somebody says
hey I'm moving this weekend just say
I'll be there but the best time to start
being a friend is right now and the
non-anxious person rejects loneliness
the non-anxious person pursues and
chooses love and connection and
friendship you have to decide however
uncomfortable it might be that you're
not going to do life alone there is no
other
[Music]
way